do you find yourself up at night worried
about what foreign policy elites think
of President Trump and do you really
care if Angela Merkel doesn't like Trump
or any of his policies I didn't think so
yet today's Politico headline was world
leaders tell Biden we need you the hill
picked up where political left off
adding global leaders nudging Biden to
enter 2020 race my first thought about
this was wait a second why are we
celebrating foreign countries meddling
in US elections I thought foreign power
is using influence to affect our vote
choose our candidates was a bad thing
huh but they please from officials
urging Biden to run they started at last
month's Munich Security Conference
did you have a card you can get me
through I don't have a card
well Biden offered this cryptic line to
the assembled crowd I promise you I
promise you as my mother would say this
too shall pass we will be back we will
be back don't have any doubt about their
getting ready for the old wine cellars
at the EU again
well Biden has long passed himself off
as a foreign policy maven an expert and
I guess compared to Cory Booker and like
Gillibrand and bado
at least he does have some experience in
international relations the only problem
is he served eight years in an
administration that was marked by one
foreign policy failure after another and
this was summed up really well in a
piece from foreign policy with this
title Joe Biden's foreign policy fantasy
you see at the end of 2016 Biden had
just written a piece in foreign affairs
claiming we are stronger and more secure
today than when President Barack Obama
and I took office in January 2009 he
said a modestly
well horse hockey at the total delusion
let's just do a quick review shall we
number one Biden support for the hideous
Iran deal if we can take the nuclear
bomb off the table it's better dealing
with those bad guys that ever deal with
the bad guys and the nuclear bombs
this is a good deal for the first and
foremost for the United States it's a
good deal for the world the region and
it's a good deal for Israel who thought
this could represent a nuclear weapon
well it was a horrible deal of course
but one that Europe loved because
countries like France wanted to keep
making money doing business with the
mullahs it was shameful and let's not
forget the pallets of cash four hundred
million dollars that was also sent to
Iran in the dead of night hmm
number two failure the rise of Isis
under Obama and Biden as Uncle Joe
defended believe it or not Obama's
arming of those Syrian rebels we are
working hand in glove with the Turks
with the Jordanians with the Saudis and
with all the people in the region
attempting to identify the people who
deserve the help so that when Assad goes
and he will go there will be a
legitimate government that follows on
not an al-qaeda sponsored government
that follows on one problem the weapons
were actually going to Islamic jihadists
gold star Joe
number three failure the rise of China
accelerated under Obama and Biden
China's aggression its threats in the
South China Sea its brazen stealing of
us intellectual property it went
virtually unchecked and unchallenged by
the Obama and Biden administration and
let's not forget Benghazi in the fall of
Libya a total disaster and a tragedy we
lost a US Ambassador three fine
Americans and then the obama-biden crew
lied about the reason for the attack at
the time Romney was nipping at their
heels in 2012 remember that was
September October in 2012 and finally
the failed Russian reset Russia's
annexation of Crimea its move into
eastern Ukraine which gave Putin power
prestige and a much-needed foreign
policy win I could go on and on and on
Obama and Biden fully embraced though
this new world order and they were loved
because they embraced agreements like
the trans-pacific partnership in the UN
climate Accord Trump comes in and he
rejects both because he believes rightly
they seated too much American power in
decision-making to far-flung foreign
bureaucracies but Biden oh he would
return things to the old status quo the
trans-pacific partnership is another
disaster done and pushed by special
interests who want to rape our country
do we expect other countries to pay
their fair share for the cost of their
defense Americans will be the captains
of their own destiny once again or Trump
actually goes to Brussels and he
declares that the era of free riding
from NATO is over the American taxpayer
is fed up and the foreign policy elites
gathered just bristled can't do that
well he did our economy is the strongest
in the g7 it's the envy of the world
there are economies in many cases are
faltering after decades of social
welfare spending in high taxes so of
course the old euro elites they want to
return to the old status quo when they
had all the power now those populist
were challenging them and let's face it
nothing says status quo more than Amtrak
Joe he is the foreign policy
establishment and even members of that
Club they think Biden was a disaster
like former Obama defense secretary Bob
gates who wrote in his memoir quote
Biden has been wrong on nearly every
major foreign policy and national
security issue over the past four
decades ouch oh but none of that matters
to like Council on Foreign Relations
here or progressive European officials
abroad Spain's former foreign minister
gave it all away in an interview with
Politico noting that Biden is quote
deeply committed to the transit
community and the rules-based
international order here's a translation
okay committed to empowering the global
elites and swollen global bureaucracies
who make the rules and set the
priorities for you the American people
yay
no but with only 5 percent was about 5
percent of American voters focused on
foreign policy or national security
issues I would expect that the electric
electorate will focus on pocketbook
issues in 2020 and as memory serves
Uncle Joe wasn't too hot on those either
and that's the angle